salut quelques joueurs sont passés on
attaque la suite de fan du Sound
yoursson en fait je reprends mes notes
de l'autre fois si vous avez pas vu la
première vidéo c'est une boîte
casse-tête extrêmement difficile qu'à
peu près 1000 mouvements trop long trop
long trop dur je l'ai fait quand une
fois et en gros à la fin de la vidéo
j'ai été capable de la remettre dans son
état d'origine mais j'avais compris un
truc je m'étais arrêté sur le fait qu'il
fallait que j'arrive à déplacer ses deux
lamelles pour faire ensuite les autres
dans un ordre précis j'ai compris une
partie de l'imbrication et je me faisais
des codes que j'espère pouvoir relire
c'est parti pour la suite la suite
d'ailleurs juste avant j'ai une vérité à
vous dire une vérité presque nickel mais
comment ça bienvenue dans ce nouvel
épisode des dossiers du nord de vérité
presque nickel oui les dossiers du Nord
VPN sponsorisés par nordvpn aujourd'hui
nous allons découvrir la vérité sur les
pyramides qui ont été créés par nordvpn
et ouais mon gars pourquoi donc et bien
tout simplement pour distraire Cléopâtre
qui nous le rappelons avec eu plus
proche de l'iPhone que de la
construction des pyramides ça c'est vrai
pour tout vous dire entre deux raisins
elle dessinait sur du papier russe puis
elle s'est lassée alors elle a commencé
à dessiner sur une tablette tactile elle
dessinait elle mange manger des raisins
puis à la finit par dessiner des raisins
évidemment il était tellement beau
qu'elle a voulu les partager sur les
réseaux sociaux mais interdiction
d'utiliser le wifi des palais fait
risquer de se faire pirater mais grâce
aux pyramides il sera envoyé les IP
entre elles à la plus crée son blog sans
crainte avec la couverture cybersécurité
nordvpn nordvpn chiffre et toutes ces
données caché son adresse IP elle
pouvait donc surfer sur la toile sans
aucun problème norvpn veillez pour elle
contre les cyberattaques comme les
fausses publicités pour des crèmes
solaires ou des photos de profil en
Egypte en plus il proposait une offre
sur les trois différents packs pas que
c'est essentiel uniquement nordvpn parce
qu'avancer nordvpn plus Nord-Pas pack
ultime nordvpn plus Nord-Pas plus norde
le cœur Bref déjà à l'époque nordvpn
était le plus complet et le plus rapide
du marché clairement le seul aussi est
le plus simple d'utilisation avec sa
connexion automatique si vous cherchez
un VPN alors faites comme elle qui avait
cliqué sur le lien dans la description
pour bénéficier d'une remise
extraordinaire en fait Cléo elle me dit
de vous dire que si vous n'avez pas
satisfait en 30 jours vous serez
remboursé alors merci Nord VPN et à
bientôt pour une nouvelle vérité presque
nickel cette vérité est en rétablie
c'est important de rétablir l'effet on
réaction on perd pas de temps là mon but
est donc de trouver on va dire la
séquence qui va me permettre de pousser
lui
vers le bas c'est ça qu'on voulait faire
on voulait le mettre vers le haut non on
voulait le mettre vers le haut de
trouver la séquence qui me permet en
tout cas de le bouger parce que j'avais
terminé en réussissant à bouger tout
cela à l'époque à l'extérieur tout cela
là et c'était tout cela là-bas mais il
me manquait lui donc on va faire ça oui
parce que ça m'avait libéré tout ce côté
j'avais pas pu bouger ce truc là
complètement ce petit truc là en partant
mal si si un les gars c'est ça c'est
s'ouvrir non le seum le somme de la mort
et donc pour le déplacer puisque tout
est en croisillon si vous avez pas suivi
la première vidéo tout est un briquet il
faut que je trouve un peu la séquence
que je dois faire avec celui-ci par en
gros on va se la mettre
donc là j'ai tout le cas à zéro je vais
me faire mon chiffrement habituel je
crois qu'on travaillait que sur ces
trois là il est pas sur le dernier ah
oui ça c'est ouais ça c'était comment
pour bouger lui et comment pour bouger
le lui ça je l'avais noté ah super je
m'étais laissé des notes pour le bien du
futur parce que j'avais trouvé comment
le pousser vers là en disant - 1 - 1
donc -1
là lui il est en 1 Lite pour le mettre
en -1 je me souviens c'était tac je
crois moins en moins un et donc un comme
ça on va voir si je me suis bien remis
dans le même sens donc là j'ai moins un
moins un qui va me permettre de pousser
lui ici voilà donc ça ok je suis bien
dans le même sens et je comprends ce que
je me suis dit l'autre fois ce qui est
quand même relativement positif et donc
là c'était c'est ces trois là un peu que
je me noterai bien
[Musique]
c'est de l'abnégation ça mon pote quel
autre youtubeur vous fait ça sans
déconner
donc ça c'est toutes les combinaisons
que je dois essayer là pour ces trois là
pour ensuite pouvoir déduire comment on
peut bouger celui-ci là et donc dans ces
cas-là je cherche ces trois lamelles là
pour bouger lui il y a de fortes chances
que lui doit ressortir par là-bas et ça
c'est un truc qu'on a jamais fait encore
donc il faut absolument qu'on trouve ça
et d'ailleurs c'est ce que j'avais prévu
puisque je m'étais mis celle là je suis
en train de refaire le raisonnement de
l'autre fois mais bon écoute tant mieux
ça c'est pas grave donc ici c'est -1
c'est -1 - 1 le triple 1 1 0
triple -1 - 1 - 1 0 - 1 - 1 - 1 0 - 1 0
11 0 1 - 1 0 0 - 1 0 - 1 0 - 1 - 1 - 1
donc là j'ai à moins à -1 - 1 - 20 c'est
que -1 - 20 - 20
- 0 1
0,5 je discute pas tellement avec vous
là ah non c'est concentré
moi je viens vous raconter une histoire
le temps qui le temps qui finit je sais
pas où du tout où tu en es donc je me
suis un peu présomptueux c'est ça
la gifle du coup moi mon anecdote
c'était je suis resté un peu perplexe
c'est le cousin du Père Castor bien sûr
en coco ce matin je quand je venais au
boulot il y a un mec qui m'a arrêté
voilà qui m'a fait excusez-moi donc je
m'arrête j'enlève mes écouteurs et il
monte sur son portable il a une page
internet ouverte avec le site et un
endroit où il devait aller il y avait
écrit le nom de la rue il me fait
excusez-moi c'est où cette rue ça te
semble pas bizarre toi puisqu'il est sur
son plan il est surtout sur Internet et
demande c'est où la rue
voilà c'était ça mon intervention mais
si tu as pas trouvé ça tant bizarre
peut-être parce que tu étais concentré
mais vous je sais pas est-ce que ça vous
semble c'est encore des gens qui vous
demandent des directions
parce que des gens qui vous parlent
encore une bonne question ça est-ce que
les gens parlent encore est-ce qu'il y a
encore vraiment de la discussion
maintenant est-ce que tout ne passe pas
vraiment on discute encore beaucoup tu
vois c'est ça la question parce que ça
veut dire qu'il faut que je change la
position de lui pour pouvoir bouger lui
mais parce que tu vois parce que c'est
pas un peu ce que j'essaie je suis en
train de dire est-ce qu'il y a encore du
dialogue il faut le mettre au moins un
on s'appelle plus on envoie des messages
qui laissent encore des messages sur les
répondeurs d'ailleurs plus grands
puisqu'on les écoute même les messages
répondeur je crois que je suis pas allé
écouter mon répondeur depuis bien un an
tout j'ai des trucs super important
non non franchement tu fais ça je
finirai jamais je referai pas j'ai une
patience pas de problème tant que j'ai
peur j'arrête de bonne fin de vidéo
[Musique]
si je trouve une pièce au chocolat je me
ramène une ok salut
[Musique]
alors Fabien quoi de neuf
t au courant
j'avais rien d'autre après c'est nul ton
truc
[Musique]
vers nature chargeur
c'est pas terrible revoit la vanne mais
c'est vraiment les trois séquences donc
de 29 possibilités de ces trois lamelles
selon la possibilité de cette lamelle
donc quand elle était à zéro on a fait
toute la possibilité là je la mets à une
et je me retape toutes les possibilités
c'est un délire c'est un délire mais
c'est la seule vraiment manière
d'avancer c'est un truc de fou ce que
c'est
attention Fabien
ceci est un
attention
braquage
3 sur 10 peut mieux faire
[Musique]
ok là j'ai ouvert deux pans en même
temps c'est la première fois qu'on fait
ça et ça n'ouvre pas ça n'ouvre rien
j'ai envie de serrer
il y a un truc dedans
je suis déprimé parce que je suis
capable maintenant de de libérer
n'importe quoi je pense n'importe quel
côté
par exemple non
genre
Marie-Antoinette quand elle avait des
ans quand elle elle attendait des
enfants
elle était au château au château de
Versailles est-ce qu'on pourrait dire
que c'était l'enceinte du château
moi je sais maintenant tous les mettre
d'un côté comme je veux
et donc là c'est un fin libéré des
petits terroirs parce que tu vois les
petits tiroirs ils sont bloqués par le
bois tu vois c'est frustrant ah c'est
super frustrant et là là mon petit pote
je sais je dis dedans est-ce que il y a
une manière de faire qui va permettre
d'ouvrir tu vois ce que je veux dire
est-ce que cette bille elle a un impact
sur ta santé mentale il y a moyen
donc bien en fait des éliminations on
fait des éliminations alors nous on
élimine d'abord Sophie sauf si désolé
Sophie en commentaire tu peux dire au
revoir et après tu te déconnectes de
YouTube premier hypothèse c'était les
lamelles qui bloquaient on voit que non
deuxième et peut-être quelque chose les
relie comme ça de par deux on ne sent
pas de vibration peut-être ça relie sur
le côté avec un petit système de canal
et dans ces cas là faut libérer ici et
ici en même temps tu vois mais non on
sent bien que c'est pas ça donc ça veut
dire qu'il y a quelque chose quand même
qui bloque objectivement la levée
il nous reste la petite boule à
l'intérieur ça roule pas ça glisse ça
fait ça se déporte d'un côté et de
l'autre donc quoi ça doit taper
exactement un endroit il y a une petite
cible de merde
tu vois il y a un trou là
bon pas du tout j'ai eu l'impression
[Rires]
je fais comment tu sais comment tu sais
non
tu imagines la casse-tête de castor ça
va parce qu'en gros ça c'est mon point
de repère si je le perds je sais plus où
j'habite et tu l'as déjà perdu une fois
tu le repères
bon alors vous dites est-ce qu'il va
nous faire en trois vidéos ou est-ce
qu'il va le finir il va le finir est-ce
qu'il va nous le faire entre tu viens de
répondre pardon non on va le faire bien
dans cette vidéo là mais on va le faire
en trois tournages pourquoi parce que
j'ai un spectacle et j'avais une
interview avant que j'avais oublié donc
je reviens on a l'impression que j'ai
pas évolué tellement aujourd'hui mais je
vous jure que si le quand je vais
revenir on va se les basculer de l'autre
côté voir ce qui se passe à tout de
suite et tout de suite c'est quand tout
de suite c'est maintenant quelques jours
on passait on va pas se mentir la vie à
continuer malgré tout mais je lâche pas
l'affaire cousin cousine j'ai la patate
à faire peur la plus alcaline tu as la
réfléchis
je reprends toutes mes notes et donc on
avait libéré ces deux là ça n'avait
servi à rien j'ai un peu tripoté
maintenant on en est à la phase et on va
libérer les deux autres
donc lui on y était presque donc c'était
pas bien compliqué alors attends
réfléchis mais réfléchis bien Fabien
vas-y c'est pas mal ça non il faut il
faut
parce que là je commence à devenir
vraiment spécialiste de ce casse-tête et
donc tac
là on a lui
matin on voit quelque chose là mais
regardez celui-ci il se libère attends
je vais rien compris mais la dernière
fois ça se libérerait pas non en fait la
dernière fois c'est lui et lui qu'on a
libéré et ça s'ouvrait pas donc là j'ai
attaqué celui-là et celui-là il s'ouvre
et c'est lui je sais pas encore bah
laisse-moi regarder dedans
c'est parce que bon il m'a tellement
choqué truc que je sais plus mais non
mais c'était sûr qu'il y a avoir un qui
s'ouvre au moins
oh [ __ ] oh non non
c'était juste aller ouvrir le truc et
c'est bon pourquoi c'est quoi c'est la
fin
bon je viens d'ouvrir alors quand tu
ouvres là là ça marche c'est un truc de
bâtard la vis qui a là c'est ça qui doit
retenir en fait les autres de l'autre
côté c'est sûr il y a une vis ici
effectivement cette vis-là est-ce que
j'avais je pense qu'en fait il y a une
vis sur tous qui bloque en bas en fait
OK et pourquoi ça se lève pas tous alors
parce que je pense que là c'est évidé
mais c'est pas évident les autres et que
là il y a un bout de bois qui fait que
ça ça coince donc je pense que
maintenant on va avoir un mécanisme
interne à trouver qui va nous permettre
d'amener cette encoche devant les autres
pour les ouvrir un par un donc ça veut
dire qu'il va falloir se taper les
quatre un par un tu l'as ou pas ouais
ouais bah alors moi ce que je te propose
regarde si je fais ça ça tourne manière
on n'a pas le choix il va falloir y
aller allez on essaie maintenant je vais
essayer de libérer lui pour voir ce qui
se passe mais en gardant lui accessible
je connais par cœur ce truc c'est à dire
que là il faut que je rentre lui là au
moins d'un cran pour l'instant et je
sais que pour ça il faut que eux ils
soient en moins un pour être en moins un
il faut d'abord que je rentre lui là
comme ça pour pouvoir ensuite rentrer
lui ensuite il faut que je ressorte lui
pour contrer lui une fois que j'ai fait
ça je rentre plus je fais ça tac ensuite
je repousse fiche je ressors et là je
suis en - 1 allez blé qu'est-ce qu'il y
a maintenant lui il faut que je
l'enfonce complètement pour l'enfoncer
complètement je dois être en 1 - 1 tu
veux regarde bien voir
[Musique]
[ __ ] c'est pas ça ma théorie là selon
moi il est censé se lever lui maintenant
regarde je viens de le libérer il se
lève pas ce bâtard là il y a ici là il y
a une vis là c'est pareil là donc tu vas
aller me chercher un petit un petit
chalumeau et je peux dire que la vie si
on va la faire fondre donc peut-être ça
a libéré lui ou celui d'en face en fait
j'en sais foutrement rien du coup tu es
obligé de faire il est horrible ce
casse-tête frérot
bon ben je vais essayer de faire cette
ligne là donc d'abord
tac tac
alors comment ça marche ah ben voilà
voilà donc là en fait ok donc
la tige là le la 10 elle bloquait là et
quand on a fait ça celle-là bouger et on
peut continuer maintenant à tourner on
avait fait Excalibur mais celui-là il
est pas mal ça moi j'ai envie de savoir
il y a quoi DRC
[Rires]
il approche et tu feras un petit lutin
et tu regardes il fait et là il
disparaît dans la fumée c'est sûr qu'il
y a ça bon alors
ça ça ça une ferme arrête
c'est pas c'est pas c'est vide c'est pas
ça
[Musique]
j'y vais là
de soutenir la chaîne n'oubliez pas de
profiter de 4 mois offerts pour tout
abonnement de 2 ans avec une garantie de
remboursement sans risque pendant 30
jours en passant non pas par l'Égypte
même par le lien en description c'est
plus rapide sauf qu'un casse-tête bien
résolu un casse-tête bien résolu et
remonté par quelqu'un d'autre hors
caméra c'est ce qu'on m'avait dit après
j'ai pas tant de temps et est-ce que ce
serait pas un bon live sur Tik Tok ça
remise en place d'un premier mec qui
remet un casse-tête en live sur Tik Tok
je vous donne rendez-vous en 2023 sur
Tik Tok je ferai une pré-annonce c'est
bien et je le ferai gagner après à mes
abonnés Tik Tok
spectacle sur la tournée on en discutera
à la fin ou pas prenez soin de vous à
très bientôt Ciao
bonne année au fait